you
Don war is a strategy game that takes
place in the 41st millennia this is a
galaxy where humans and a whole series
of alien races are fighting basically a
war that's been going on for thousands
and thousands of years and you know
what's really interesting to me about
Don war and the story we want to tell
them there is like how are you a hero in
the midst of this type of giant
endless-warr the Eldar this really
interesting faction there are species
that's been around since the dawn of
time essentially they used to run the
galaxy that led them to decadence and
essentially led their empire to fall the
elder that survived to the present are
the ones who step away from that corrupt
society and are following a sort of
warrior path they have this whole tragic
edge and then they have this whole
highly arrogant edge together they shall
achieve righteous victory the orcs are
this great lunatic horde that we get to
play with
they're much wilder than the very
controlled eldar and the very regimented
space marines they absolutely are funny
when you're outside the settings but in
this setting if you're standing in front
of an orc they are terrifying they're
these homicidal monsters who are going
to rip your head off and laugh at your
corpse yeah abriel Angelo's is the face
of the dawn of war franchise in a lot of
ways he has gone through a great deal
over his career and that's something we
wanted to bring in to dawn of war three
we like to say that there are no good
guys in donna war and that's true
certainly you empathize with gabriel and
with the other heroes but he's
definitely done things that make you
hesitate and he condemned his home world
to extermination because he found heresy
there and that's something that weighs
on him but it's also a decision he owned
and I think in that way he really
captures what's important about the
Bloodraven maka is a returning character
for us she was first introduced in the
original dawn of war and we haven't
really heard from her since then when
last we saw her she was very much in
charge there was no other eldar that she
was answering to now we find her and
she's sort of in a secondary role she
wants to regain that role but she has to
find the ways to guide her people the
orcs really come alive when there's a
layer of madness and then there's some
really smart deviousness happening under
the surface in a story sense we have a
hero in gorguts who's our orc chieftain
who's more cunning than the average or
who has a plan
he's still punching people in the face
and ripping their heads off and mounting
them on spikes and doing all these crazy
or key things but he's doing it with an
agenda oh we're telling story about
characters not about entire armies and
it's an incredibly challenging but
rewarding thing to dig into especially
with a strategy game we make games where
there's a massive army of hundreds of
Units clashing and it's easy for that to
feel disposable what the story brings to
that is to bring context and that's what
elevates it but then there's also how we
create an environment where it feels
like there's a context in the rationale
and that's where things like all the
audio barks for all the characters and
you know hearing the Space Marines call
out to the Emperor that just creates a
whole tenor to how this universe works
how combat feels that's our whole
setting
the animatics have a very sort of
tapestry like quality the atmosphere was
a huge huge thing for me I love the idea
of conveying that sense of mist and fog
and I like to imagine that in 40 first
millennium with the kind of weapons that
we're talking about that are so
fantastic and so powerful you're going
to be dealing with almost this constant
haze in this constant sense of never
really being able to see everything and
focus at any one time because there's
just so many layers of dust and
atmosphere that are locking things off
the animatics capture that so
marvelously those cinematics really
allowed us to emphasize those things as
important and create some key emotional
images that then resonate through the
rest of the game there's tons of amazing
things that happen in a cinematics
Killick hands get destroyed and meteors
fall from the sky and thunder hawks
disgorge space marines on to a bunch of
orcs there's just so many layers of dust
and atmosphere that are blocking things
off the animatics capture that so
marvelously we are so excited for fans
to play through the campaign and
experience these cinematics themselves
you
you